[拍手]
[音楽]
最初からなかなか
緊張するんですがよろしくお願いします
これは僕が高校生の時の写真なんです
けれども
僕小学校中学校とずっとサッカーをやって
いましてでまぁサッカー少年ではあったん
ですけどもサッカーはそんな上手じゃ
なかったんですねずっとあの右サイド
ベンチが
定位置で
監督に近い方ってのは結構ポイントなん
ですけどそういった中学生活を過ごしてい
ましたでだからといって勉強も
めちゃくちゃできたわけではなくて
でそんな自分自身が中学生の時に居場所を
見出したのはゲームセンターの中でした
もちろん学校には通っていたんですけれど
もずっとゲームセンターでパチスロを打つ
という中学生活を
過ごしていまして一時はコイン5000枚
貯めるっていう記録も残してでそれをお
年玉を全部そこにつぎ込んだりとか時には
親のお金をちょっと抜いてしまって怒られ
てしまったこともありましたがそんな中学
生でした
で中学生や高校生の時はいわゆる思春期と
いう風に言われたりもしますけども自分
自身のことを考えたりとかとても揺らぐ
時期だなというふうに感じています自分は
何に興味があるんだろうとか
将来どんな仕事に就くんだろうとかどんな
大人になりたいんだろうとかそんなことを
考える時期です
それを学校の先生や親に話してみるとまず
は良い成績が取れればいい人生が送れる
からまずは勉強頑張りなよ」っていう風に
言われてあんま真剣に扱ってもらえなかっ
た気がしたりあるいは
友達にそれを話そうとしても何をお前
真面目な話してるんだよっていう風に言わ
れてちょっと照れくさい気持ちになったり
もして
自分自身の表現の行き場がゲームセンター
の中しかなかったんだなっていうことを
大人になってから気づくようになりました
そこから自分の中で表現っていうのが一つ
のキーワードになっています
今の社会では中学生や高校生子供若者だけ
ではなくて大人も表現できない社会になっ
ているんじゃないかなっていう風に感じて
います世の中では多様性を認めようという
ふうに言う割にちょっと個性的なことをし
たりとかなんか飛び抜けたことをすると
あいつは変な奴だっていう風にレッテルを
つける社会じゃないかなっていう風に感じ
ています
これまでは
経済成長という目標にみんなで足並みを
揃えてくる社会でした右向けば右左向けば
左それが求められて同じ目標にみんなで
向かっていけばよかったでもそんな社会は
もう終わりました僕は生まれてからは後継
機は全然経験していないしずっと
経済が
伸びている社会ではありません
ただ私たちはそんな社会に生きてきたこと
によって表現しないことに慣れてしまっ
たりだとか表現しないことが当たり前に
なってしまったんじゃないかなっていう
ふうに感じています
そこで僕はこれを変えるためどうしたら
いいかなっていう風に考えて一つの社会
実験を始めることにしました
それがみんなの図書館三角という
施設図書館ですこんな感じの小さな施設
図書館なんですけれども
焼津駅前通り商店街という商店街の空き
店舗を活用してこんな商店街を運営してい
ます
もう一つの背景があって今人口がどんどん
減少していたりだとか
税収が
減少したりだとかそんな社会ではこれまで
の当たり前を維持できなくなるんじゃない
かなっていうふうに考えています
これまでの社会では
政治家任せ行政任せでもどんどん都市が
発展していったりだとか
町が良くなることもあったかもしれません
でもこれからではこれからは
政治家任せ行政任せ誰か任せではもう限界
が来てるんじゃないかなっていうふうに
考えています
そこで自分たちが住みたい街は自分たちが
作っていくんだこの発想が必要じゃないか
という風に考えています
これを僕は
施設公共というふうに言いました私から
立ち上がる公共という意味ですもう少し
簡単に解説をすると
昔から
皇居
氏という3つのレイヤーで世の中のことが
語られることがあります行政が提供する公
のサービスそして私たち個人その間に今日
という
友というコモンズともいうふうに言ったり
もしますがこんなレイヤーがあって
施設公共はある意味公共氏の学校の今日の
レイヤーを私発で立ち上げていこうという
そういう発想です
だから三角は
酸化三角の三角から来ていてどこにも実は
三角形がないですねそして実はこの名前を
つけてから気づいたんですけれどもここを
三角の住所は3丁目3-33だったんです
この後僕は車を買ったんですけど車の
ナンバーも333にしましてそれから
ずっと僕の中のラッキーナンバーというか
何か困った時は3を選ぶという風にしてい
ます
そしてこの
民営の
施設の図書館を運営していくための
根幹となる仕組みは1箱本棚オーナー制度
と呼ばれるシェア型の図書館の仕組みです
これは何かというとお金を払って人に本を
貸すお金を払ってもらったら本棚を持って
もらって自分の本を貸してもらえるよって
いうそういう本棚オーナーの仕組みを考え
ました
月額2000円を持っていただくと1箱の
本棚を持つことができて人に本を貸すこと
ができます
これをいろんな人に説明すると
詐欺みたいな仕組みだなっていう風に言わ
れますなんでそんな
儲けにもならない本棚を変えなきゃいけ
ないんだもしかしたら
貸した本が誰かに取られちゃうかもしれ
ないし
破れて帰ってくるかもしれないしそんな本
誰が借りるんだっていう風に言われたこと
もあるんですが現在は60人以上が
契約をしてくださっていて
キャンセル待ちも出るぐらいの人気ぶりに
なっています自分の好きな作家さんだけの
本を並べるという方もいらっしゃいますし
一つのテーマに絞って今月は例えば月の本
を選ぶ
星の本を選ぶという風にテーマを絞って
本棚を並べる方もいらっしゃいます
そしてもう一つ重要なことがあります
2000円×60〜の本棚だと月12万円
の売り上げになりますがこれでは家賃や
水道光熱費いろんな経費は払うことができ
ても人件費を払うことができない
給料が出せないんですねじゃあどうしよう
かという風に考えたのが人件費を稼ぐん
じゃなくて人件費をかけない運営の仕方
です
三角に入っていただいて左のスペースは
チャレンジショップになっています実は
ここは
週1回から無料で自分のお店を出店できる
そういうスペースになっています
毎週月曜日は
子育て世代のお母さんがイラストレーター
をされていてハンドメイド雑貨のお店をし
てくださっていたりだとか
火曜日水曜日木曜日はコーヒースタンドが
出店したりもしています
他にも2000円払ってるホンダの
オーナーさんたちはきっとお店番もしたい
だろうという風に考えて本棚オーナーには
お店番する権利がありますというふうに
伝えています
そうしたらお店はしていいんですかって
いう風に言ってくれる方が出てきてこの方
はあまりにもお店番をたくさんしてくれる
のでおめでとうございます名誉副館長です
ということで1年経ったところで名刺を
渡して今度は宣伝役も買って出ていただく
という風に運営をしています
まさにみんなの
参画によってできた図書館じゃないかなと
いうふうに考えています
表現をすることと
施設公共を作ることには大きなつながりが
あるというふうに僕は考えています
本来公共っていうのは表現の集合体なん
じゃないかなっていうふうに考えていてと
いうのも
元々公共施設だったりとか公共空間だっ
たりとかは自分たちが住みたい豊かに住み
続けるために作ってきたものじゃないかと
思いますそれはまさにその街に住む人々が
こんな街に住みたいこんな場所があったら
いいのにというそれぞれの思いを
折り重ねながら表現をしながら作ってきた
場所が公共なんじゃないかなっていう風に
考えています
だけど私たちはお客様でいることに
慣れてしまいまし
た公共施設や公共空間で何か問題があると
とりあえず行政にクレームをして
そうした結果例えば公園にはどんどん禁止
看板が立ち並んだりとかどんどん使い
づらい公共空間になっているんじゃないか
なっていう風に感じています
そして結果として
ルールや規則にがんじがらめになって
しまって生きづらい生きづらい社会を私達
自身が作ってしまってきてしまったんじゃ
ないかなとそういうふうに感じることも
あります
だからこそ僕は三角という小さな
図書館を通じて私が私である場所私が
立ち上がれる場所私の評判表現が集まる
場所を作りたいそういう風に考えています
実はこの1箱本棚オーナーの仕組みを3年
前に始めてからこの同じ仕組みを
導入してくれている
姉妹館というのが全国50回以上に広がり
ましたもう
字が小さくて全然読めないと思います
けれども
今は
沖縄から
今度は北海道
頑張らないので北海道にできたらいいなっ
ていう風に思っていますが私たちの
コンセプトに共感をしてくださってこんな
に全国に
仲間が広がり
詐欺みたいな仕組みだと言われた本棚
オーナーは今や全国2000人以上に拡大
をしています
これらを僕はミント諸島という風に名付け
ましたみんなの図書館を
ぎゅっとしてミントショットという名前
です
つい先日三角は3周年を迎えました
2020年の3月3日にオープンをして
2023年の3月3日それが三角の3周年
だったんですね
たった3年間の期間ではありましたが3
周年パーティーをやるよというふうに全国
各地あるいは地元の仲間に声をかけたら
こんなにたくさんの
仲間が集まってくれてとても楽しい時間を
過ごすことができました
三角というのはとても小さな
図書館で
全体の日本の動きの中で言うと本当に
小さな動きかもしれませんただこの場所を
通じて僕は皆と一緒にみんなの参画と一緒
に人々の表現があふれる社会を作っていき
たいなという風に考えています以上です
ありがとうございました